you
you
you
yeah
say it again
one two three four five
I'm party here this yeah
hi guys
I'm sorry are you going to meet earth
for Shannon I'm sorry does he say
there's no more time okay
[Music]
well then I may have to step down in
just a few minutes here because about
the two men in front of the White House
press secretary but the overall sense
here at the White House is that there is
a little bit of relief in the sense that
these financial backers from president
Park they are private at least for now
but anytime you have the highest court
in the land sank no president of the
United States has from prosecution
certainly concerning in president talk
he tweeted about this seven times in two
hours and so from the president but this
issue today the Supreme Court has
temporarily blocked both Congress in New
York prosecutors repeated the
president's financial records who will
not receive raise additional
constitutional and legal issues in the
courts so after years of President Trump
fighting to keep his tax returns and his
financial records that he was only going
to continue and usually before these
briefings White House press secretary
has an opportunity to speak to president
prompt to get more insight into exactly
how he's feeling so now we wait to see
if she has done that and what exactly
she says
sorry guys
hello everyone there has been no greater
champion for rectifying racial and
income disparities in America's
educational system than President Trump
every child regardless of race income
level or zip code deserves an equal
playing field of opportunity to access
the American Dream making that goal a
reality begins in our schools the
evidence is clear an analysis of 41
major urban areas found that black and
Hispanic students made the largest gains
and education and educational access
because of school choice according to a
credo study that is why President Trump
has been clear and saying in his State
of the Union for too long countless
American children have been trapped in
failing government schools to rescue
these students 18 states have created
school choice in the form of opportunity
scholarships the programs are so popular
that tens of thousands of students
remain on a waiting list now I go I call
on Congress to give 1 million American
children the same opportunity pass the
education freedom scholarships and
opportunities Act he said because no
parent should be forced to send their
child to a failing government school
well now if Democrats have their way
children will not have access to schools
at all and that is not acceptable to
President Trump
President Trump continues to fight for
equal opportunity in our schools by
boldly and firmly underscoring the
absolute necessity of America's schools
to reopen this fall the data is clear
sustained school closures hurt students
who have fewer resources the most
Mackenzie & Co created these models I
have some graphs for you to estimate the
potential impact of school closures and
they found this quote how much learning
students lose during school closures
vary significantly by access to remote
learning the quality of remote
instruction home support in the degree
of engagement as you can see in this
chart students who experience average
quality remote learning progress but at
a slower pace students who are getting
lower quality remote learning stagnates
at current grade levels and students who
are not getting instruction at home lose
significant ground with some students
dropping out altogether as you can see
in the three scenarios mapped on this
graph if students return to school in
the fall the disparities are far less
than if they returned in January of next
year or the fall of next year
where disparities and learning are
enormous but school closures affect more
than just learning as the n-double-a-cp
has pointed out for students of color at
all levels across the country school
closings create problems even more
urgent than the interruption of their
education schools also serve as a
community nexus for food and for housing
rest assured that President Trump knows
more than anyone the importance of
opening our schools which is why he has
been the most vocal advocate for
reopening and president Trump's America
make no mistake that he will continue to
be the biggest fighter for equal
opportunity in our schools and continued
access to the American dream for all and
with that I'll take questions Thank You
Kaylee I'm just curious after today's
Supreme Court rulings how was President
Trump feeling about the two justices
that he appointed to the Supreme Court
Neil Brewers and Brett Kavanaugh who
ruled against him today well the
justices are entitled to their opinion
this is an independent branch of
government but as for the decision
President Trump
underscored Smee I was just in the Oval
Office with him that it was justice
Cavanaugh who pointed out in the New
York State Court case that there was
unanimous agreement that this should be
remanded to DC to the excuse me to the
district court where the president may
raise constitutional and legal arguments
that was unanimous agreement also there
was a note in the Roberts opinion that
the New York State case basically the
grand jury said that they were
prohibited from arbitrary fishing
expeditions and initiating
investigations out of malice or intent
to harass us that language made it
pretty clear that this was a win for the
president when you were speaking to the
president in the Oval Office didn't even
thing to say
specifically about justices corsetry
Cavanaugh okay and if I put one question
about the CDC's guidelines yesterday
about reopening schools yesterday the
Vice President came out and said that he
said that the CDC was going to be
putting out new guidelines next week in
terms of reopening but the head of the
CDC he was on in our network this
morning and said that they would not be
changing those guidelines they would
just be putting out some additional
documents so can you can you explain the
discrepancy between those two the CDC
director noted that there would be
additional guidance the vice president
noted that as well but we're on the same
page with with dr. Redfield who has said
I don't want this guidance to be a
reason for schools not to be to reopen
and he said that these were not meant to
be prescriptions they are guidelines
ultimately it's up to state and local
governments as to what their guidelines
look like there are 47 states who have
issued their own guidelines so far I
would also note that the CDC recognizes
and their guidelines that many of these
things that they're recommending are not
feasible which is why they use the words
the not possible 18 times and not
feasible
nine times we want our schools to reopen
it's imperative for the health and
well-being of the child you would ask
the president whether he supports the
idea of staggered school reopening
schedules where kids go to school and
some days not others never to get with
him on that today but because of this a
pretty Supreme Court ruling we didn't
quite get to that yet but it is on my
list of things to follow up so I'm sorry
it's two different things that the vice
president and dr. Redfield described one
was changing the guidelines to guidance
that that was previously really released
and without the red Phyllis custom or
anyone's just adding supplemental
guidance on which of those is actually
happening and is the White House in
addition also planning to release its
own president why big dr. Redfield was
noting he doesn't plan to her send the
current guidance that's out there it
will be supplemental guidance but these
are not requirements and not
prescriptive it was the way he
characterized the initial guidance and
he said that this guidance should not be
used as a reason for schools and not to
reopen we all have the same goal here
it's her schools to reopen because the
health of the child absolutely depends
on it and it's an
parroted as the presentation i showed to
rectify disparities that we get these
schools open I have no announcements on
that none in the works but doesn't mean
that it won't happen
the president's tax is still under audit
and specifically which years the
president's taxes are still under audit
I don't have years for you okay let me
ask you if I can
it could release his taxes at any time
this case went all the way to the
Supreme Court his own nominees ruled
against him why shouldn't the American
public at this point believe that the
president has something he's trying to
hide first let me note something the
taxes are under audit he said he
relieved he would release them when they
are no longer under audit the justices
did not justices did not rule against
him in fact it was a unanimous opinion
saying that this needs to go back to the
district court and they even recognize
that the president has an ample arsenal
of arguments that he can make and in
fact I would show that the vast majority
laid out a roadmap for the president the
Vance majority said the president has
the right to challenge the subpoena on
any grounds permitted by state law be it
bad faith or undue burden or threat they
went on to say the president can raise
subpoenas specific constitutional
challenges I may specifically mention a
violation of the Supremacy Clause as one
thing that he can raise that they
essentially laid out a road map
this is his justices do not do anything
that you just said what I'm asked you
know is the president whatever the court
says the president can release his taxes
whenever he likes so why shouldn't
Americans at this point believe that the
president isn't trying to hide something
the media has been asking this question
for four years and for four years the
president has said the same thing his
taxes are under audits and when they're
no longer under audit he will release
them I would also note the excruciating
ruling for House Democrats who were very
much called out for their partisan games
they also subpoenaed the president's
information financial information and
Justice Roberts said far from accounting
for separation of powers concerns the
House's approach aggravates them by
leaving essentially no limits on the
congressional power to subpoena the
president's personal records so leave it
to House Democrats who did a partisan
impeachment a political witch-hunt
against this president and this
yet another part only to be rebuked by
the Supreme Court after a very quickly
Kayle hospitalizations in the country
around 50% since mid-june how can the
president say that the country is in
good shape right now so I would know
with hospitalizations I'm in a lot of
these hospitals I poke with dr. Burks
this morning about 10 to 40% in the
hospital's reaching high capacity arc
Ovid so a lot of hospitalizations aren't
pertaining to Kovac what I would also
know and I'm glad not because of code
well a lot of it is elective surgeries
and other surgeries that have opened up
about 10 to 40 percent in the hospital's
reaching capacity or KO bida lated but
I'm glad that you asked about Kovac
because I do want to take a moment to
highlight some of the things that the
federal government has done in good
shape right now with hospitalizations
going out in spite of what you said one
of the things I would note is the
mortality rate which has had if you look
at the weekend numbers a tenfold
decrease if they are you an even greater
decrease if you compare to some of our
highest days we're seeing the fatality
rate in this country come down that is a
very good thing we grieve when anyone
even one life is lost but I think it's
progress as we enter on the next phase
of this sanctions against high-level
Chinese officials over the weaker pieces
but can you speak overall what that does
to the u.s. relationship with touch with
China and doesn't jeopardize the Phase
one deal look I think with regard to I
look at these Magnitsky Act sanctions
and the administration does I'm not with
regard to phase one China deal these are
very serious sanctions that were put in
place by this administration to take
strong action against the human rights
abuses of the Chinese Communist Party I
just want to emphasize and underscore
that we sanctioned officials several of
them the party secretary his former
deputy and his current party secretary
it's also its former its former party
secretary so that was three and today's
announcement is the latest in a series
of actions by the Trump administration
so it's not just these sanctions that
were put in place there were export
controls controls the President signed
the
we ger Human Rights policy act so we've
taken a very strong stance on the side
of human rights and against the
atrocities we've seen and just so the
American public knows some of these
atrocities have been forced abortions
and sterilizations and really despicable
things that have been done this issue is
separate from the human rights is a
paramount issue it's very important we
took action we've crafted a phase 1 deal
and we hope the Chinese government will
honor that thanks Kaylee you've
mentioned that the court decision today
was a win from the presidents this
morning that he was making a general
points about deference on the principle
of absolute immunity which is the
posture that the admit that the
president took in court you know he
believes there should have been more
deference there
Justice Alito citing the Harvard Law
Review made a very good point that
constitutionally speaking the president
never sleeps the president must be ready
at a moment's notice
to do whatever it takes to preserve
protect and defend the Constitution and
the American people and we wish there
would have been more deference to that
point of view but it is a big win as
justice Cavanaugh noted that all nine
justices said this needs to be remanded
back to the lower court and that in fact
the attorney v Vance had not established
his ability to secure access to those
records instead further proceedings are
required cueing the opportunity could it
be was attorney or to look at those
documents is no not something the
president is happy about I'm wondering
in general if after this ruling and the
ruling that Calderon I know to be he
writes the ruling on the census his
criticism of judges in particular
Justice Roberts no I think what the
president what is unfit underscored to
him after all of these rulings is that
you know he need more conservative
justices on the court I mean that's
something he's very strong about it
prompted him say he'll release a list of
more conservative justices he wants on
the court so I think that's been the big
takeaway not particularly with regard to
this ruling but with the previous ones
that you
conservative judges on the court now
it's the five before yes and then there
was a nine to zero unanimous decision
that this needed to be remanded and
there is a roadmap as I noted a roadmap
set forward on how to proceed in the
lower court and there were several
arguments proposed that the president
could make in lower courts yes I've got
two questions for you one on these
rulings today the Supreme Court is
rejecting this assertion from the
president that he is immune to
investigation while he's in office does
he agree with he is not well where the
president stands as he still maintains
his initial position and he agrees with
Justice Thomas and the dissent who said
the demands on the president's time and
the importance of his tasks are
extraordinary in the office of the
president cannot be delegated to
subordinates a subpoena imposes both
demands on the president's limited time
and a burden and he went on to describe
that position so he agrees with
dissolves you he agrees with the dissent
by Justice Thomas so he takes issue with
the the point that the majority made on
absolute immunity but nevertheless I
would underscore the victory here on a
side Vance the attorney was not given
what he wanted which was access to them
he still thinks immunity is he's immune
to investigation the president still
stands decided the posture that he made
he accepts any Supreme Court opinion as
the law of the land but nevertheless
doesn't change his viewpoint he can
disagree with the opinion but he
certainly will follow it is my second
question on creditors I'll be quick
you're saying that you don't want these
CDC guidelines to be one-size-fits-all
overly prescriptive about how these
schools reopen so why is the
administration reading it one size fits
all that they all need to reopen fully
at the same time there's a way to safely
do it and there's a lot at stake you
know I mentioned him the 67,000
pediatricians represented by the
American Academy of Pediatrics who say
it's imperative schools reopened I was
underscored by another 1,500 United
Kingdom pediatricians the costs are high
when you know your network CNN is
reporting about child abuse I mentioned
the study yesterday I was a good good
piece by CNN that is a green mass of
uses alone reports of alleged child
abuse dropped almost 55 percent because
when kids are not in school a lot of
times we don't catch that abuse the
costs are too high
keep school shut down they can safely
reopen even the American Academy of
Pediatrics believes that and the
president's going to stand on the side
of the child always and no one is
disagreeing with that about child abuse
but I'm saying how can you say you're
not going to tell all those schools held
to reopen but you're going to tell them
all went there already there are 47
guidelines issued by the states there's
local guidelines that have been put in
place this can be done safely it can be
done well and the American Academy of
Pediatrics I've pointed out a lot of
what they've put out they put out their
own set of guidelines there's number of
guidelines floating out there and we
believe there's a way to safely do this
and the child will always come first in
this administration yes Kelly a lot
school follow up to Kaitlyn's first line
of questioning though is if the
president still believes he has absolute
immunity it makes him sound as though he
thinks he's above the law while he's
presently the United States at least
it's it's very it's it's almost as if
folks don't understand a legal term of
our absolute immunity is a legal term of
art and you know I can go and describe
that and maybe I can best describe that
by quoting Alexander Hamilton who was
referenced in the Thomas opinion and
Alexander Hamilton really created the
posture in the outlook that laid the
foundation for the notion of absolute
immunity and it was this energy and the
executive is a leading character in the
definition of good government it is
essential to the protection of the
community against foreign attacks it is
not less essential to the study
administration of the laws to the
protection of property against those
irregular and high-handed combinations
which sometimes interrupt the ordinary
course of justice to the security of
Liberty against the enterprises and
assaults of ambition of faction and of
anarchy a feeble executive implies
feeble execution of the government and
the point he was making is that the
executive is imbued with many
constitutional authorities many
responsibilities to protect this nation
from threats foreign and domestic and he
must be able to operate unencumbered
that's where the proposition of absolute
immunity comes from and that is what the
administration was defending in court
and we are pleased by the nine to zero
opinion to send this back to the lower
courts though we're not pleased by the
absolute immunity components
did you expand a little bit on education
secretary devatas comments today about
fun negative schools like to shift
funding to families do you do what that
means and the second question unrelated
is does the one cups have a comment on
the retirement yesterday of Inman so to
your first question I did not see
secretary de Vos his comments but as you
described them and leads me to believe
that it was a reference to the
president's tweet yesterday about
changing education funding if schools
don't reopen as I noted yesterday what
this administration's goal is is that
funding be tied to the child not to a
school district where schools are
staying closed
that's our paramount guiding principle
as to what that looks like in action
that will be forthcoming we're hopeful
that all the schools reopened in the
nation that's the goal and we are
hopeful for more education funding in
phase four as I noted I'm in with
Colonel van Minh you know I'm not going
to focus or comment on a former junior
employee I know the White House has not
spoken to him since he left and I would
refer you for further to the Army gritty
pressure from the White House to her yes
caitli picking up on the coronavirus
questions in schools though North
Carolina for instance has seen a record
high number of coronavirus related
hospitalizations more than a thousand
today and that's a five day Ryan account
for those hospitalizations so it's the
White House's position that schools in
North Carolina and hard-hit areas by
coronavirus should absolutely reopen
next month it is our opinion that
schools should reopen I'd refer you to
dr. Redfield who said yesterday head of
CDC this virus has a very limited effect
on kids he went on to say unlike the flu
kids are not driving the transmission
cycle he's in agreement with dr. Scott
add 'less Atlas a former chief of neuro
radiology at Stanford who said children
under 18 have virtually zero risk of
death from kovat virtually zero risk of
serious illness which was also
underscored by Yale School of Public
Health
professor Albert Koh the bottom line is
that the impacts of Koba 19 on children
is minimal or very low compared to other
age groups but you know what is that
risk for children is people not
reporting child abuse
these very serious consequences that are
at play and the educational disparity I
noted when kids stay home from school
it's also said yesterday however that
there wasn't enough data on how this
affects children because they weren't
originally testing children at the same
rate as adults but to the point about
places like again North Carolina where
they have been hard hit you think that
they should absolutely reopen next month
we believe that they should absolutely
reopen the schools in this country that
kids are at very low risk and I would
also quote to you the American Academy
of Pediatrics I would venture to say
those 67,000 pediatricians care very
deeply about the children that they
treat and they have said that children
and Adeline SAR at considerable
considerable risk of morbidity and in
some cases mortality should they stay
home from school this president will
fight for the health and well-being of
children yes
Thank You Kaylee Detroit last week about
hydroxychloroquine which the presence we
did it out showed that it kept deaths in
half American people have been told by
government agencies like the FDA and
some government medical experts that it
is not effective for coronavirus so what
is the American people supposed to think
what is the official position from the
administration on this possible therapy
so I'm glad you've asked this the
president has always said that he sees
hydroxychloroquine as a very promising
prophylactic but that every person
should not take it unless they get a
prescription from their doctor that's
paramount very important the president
has taken it himself as a prophylactic
and I would note that there's been a lot
of wrong studies out there that were
heavily touted like there was a Lancet
study that was published and many in the
media pounced on this Lancet study and
it questioned hydroxychloroquine and you
had folks like NBC's Glenn Kirchner
saying the president should resign over
the lancet study questioning
hydroxychloroquine and CNN spent over 90
minutes heralding the study that's now
debunked that has been detracted but
what we have found though The Lancet
study has been retracted we have seen a
Henry Ford Health System study and that
Henry Ford Health System study showed
that it is very promising leading CNN to
now tweet us
surprising new study found that the
controversial anti-malarial drug
hydroxychloroquine helped koban 19
patients better survive in hospitals and
the CEO of Henry Ford Medical Group said
it's important to note that in the right
settings this potentially could be a
lifesaver for patients so our position
is where we always were where the
president was weeks and weeks before the
study ever came out that this was a
promising drug but it should only be
taken in consultation with your doctor
for an emergency use I would refer you
to the FDA on that if I may follow up to
what the president talks about a few
weeks ago regarding an T back saying
that this administration's plan to
designate it as a terrorist organization
we haven't really heard anything else
about that is that still the plan or
what does that happen so that was in a
department of justice on saying that
they will prosecute these cases as
domestic terrorist cases so I'd refer
you to the DOJ as to how that's working
operationally but the DOJ has arrested
many individuals including seven out in
Portland Oregon for a variety of fences
including attacks on law enforcement so
we're working hard to ensure that an
Tifa does not dominate the streets the
seven administration stands against that
kind of law they think they should still
be designated a terrorist organization
the president stands by what he said one
question on Cyrus Vance the New York DA
taxes trans does a troubling history of
protecting predators in attacking
Republicans
case in point for non New Yorkers in
2011 he worked to reduce Epstein's bull
predator status in 2015 NYPD had audio
evidence of Weinstein admitting rape and
Vance's office refused prosecute all
this while attacking President Trump's
family and their enterprises given this
history what does president Trump's
views advance from both a personal
standpoint and a political standpoint is
this Vance just I mean is he just
politically abusing the court system
what is our chance of news on him yeah
you raised some very good points about
the partisan attorney in Manhattan you
know Justice Alito said this in his
opinion it really stood
to me he said as for the potential use
of subpoenas to harass we need not
exhibit a naivete from which ordinary
citizens are free as we have recognized
a president is an easily identifiable
target there are more than 2300 local
prosecutors and district attorneys in
the country many local prosecutors are
elected and many prosecutors have
ambitions for higher elective office
bring inside Vance a Democrats someone
who just as Thomas pointed out something
very interesting just as Thomas noted
that the district attorney for the
county of New York
Cyrus Vance served a subpoena on the
president's personal accounting firm
that quote was nearly identical to a
subpoena issued by a congressional
committee requesting nearly 10 years of
the president's financial records so the
partisan attorney
the Democrat from New York is aiding and
abetting by the Democrats the lawless
Democrats like Nancy Pelosi who have
pursued this president with bogus
charges of collusion with bogus charges
in the Pietschmann inquiry and are now
pursuing this only to be rebuked by the
Supreme Court and assisted by science
for non lawyers I mean it's there's
legal recourse against overly political
DA's out here or is this just so I have
to yeah you know this was an individual
who was elected at the state level so I
guess they were course would be the
ballot box but I would also note just on
that point that yet President Obama and
Vice President Biden's Biden who were
caught spying on the Trump campaign the
opposition party you had former Vice
President Biden in the Oval Office just
before the inauguration talking about
the Logan Act when later the Logan Act
was weaponized and used against
Lieutenant General Michael Flynn in a
way that was so unfair and a grave
miscarriage of justice but you have
Obama and Biden who get away with this
but yet we need to go investigate
President Trump it really is quite
nonsense cool thanks Kaylee in-person
toys tweets about the Supreme Court
decisions this morning he said he thinks
the court treated him differently and it
would have treated other presidents so
does he think this was a political
decision by the Supreme Court or that
politics or personal views somehow
entered into their legal reasoning so I
think you were referring to the tweet
about broad death
and what he was trying to note there
what he was noting was just that there
was should have been further deference
to this notion that I read by Alexander
Hamilton and others of absolute immunity
to allow the executive and the president
to is a very important job of protecting
this country and all the other tasks
given to a president of the United
States Supreme Court there's a delay in
ruling that they would never have given
for another president yeah what I would
also point you with regards to that I I
think Justice Alito hit on this he said
in the Clinton case for example the
court held that a sitting president
could be sued in federal courts but the
court took pains to reserve judgment on
the question of whether a comparable
claim might succeed in the state
tribunal any direct control by a state
court over the president the court
observes might raise concerns about
protecting federal officers from
possible local prejudice so that is to
say that even back in the Clinton case
where federal court prosecutions were
green-lighted they gave their grave
reservations for a state court
proceeding of this nature so I think he
was noticing noting the distinguishing
features there yes I'd like to ask a
clarifying question from something that
I said earlier the president you said
would like to see more conservative
justices is he comfortable with the
number of nine justices there's nothing
in the law that says he has to only have
nine what he consider appointee more so
the president has never mentioned adding
other justices but the Democrat Party
has as a way to get around I guess the
the rulings they don't like the question
about the unemployment numbers from
today
1.3 million additional claims in the
last week a bit of a slowing down are
you concerned that the numbers continue
to be so high still so I would note that
the numbers fell 100,000 this was the
14th consecutive weekly decline that
we've seen and from its peak in late
March initial claims are down 5.6
million also looking at continuing
claims a number another metric that we
that came out today they reflect actual
benefit payments and those fell 700,000
from its peak in May 8th the week of May
8th and they are down nearly 7 million
and combined as Larry Kudlow was shared
with me those facts in May and June the
Bureau of Labor Statistics reported that
8 million
skåne iein as Larry likes to say the
v-shaped rebound continues are there any
concerns that those particularly today
the market seems to notice the
unemployment claims more so than it has
in recent weeks I would say that the two
jobs reports the eight million together
both record-breaking months are very
encouraging signs and we like what we
see on the horizon of course there's
more work to be done but we have the
jobs president at the helm to do that
work did hi the Health Department
Director in Tulsa has said president
Trump's rally there likely contributed
to a big surge in coronavirus cases in
the area that does the president now
regrets holding that rally so we have
not seen data to reflect that and know
we don't regret holding the rally yes
Trump discussed the issue of funding for
the didn't come up in the discussions
that I was a part of but I'm grateful
that you bring up the wall which is
being built that accelerated pace you
know more than 500 miles by the end of
the year and we really appreciate the
help of the Mexican government and
securing the border with the troops that
they've provided the president actually
in government still in tribute like
directly defines that again I'm not
aware of their other discussions they
may have had but what I would note is
the USMC a that Mexico is a big part
making happen is bringing tons and tons
and tons of money and revenue into the
United States and we're very grateful
for that yes thank you very two
questions first of all giving United
Airlines recent announcement that they
might have to furlough some 36,000
workers does the president support
extending the aid that was already given
to the airlines further and second on
vaccines does the president have any
views on whether or not
K through 12 students should be mandated
to get vaccinated against Kovac 19
what's a vaccine is safe and effective
so I haven't talked to him either about
that point specifically on vaccinations
or the airline extension but I can
circle back yes and so one thing I think
I got to every
so just one last note I want to leave
everyone with because I do think it's a
very important point it's just that
there is a Rasmussen poll that came out
recently that showed 64% of Americans
are concerned about the growing
criticism of America's police and that
it will lead to a shortage of police
officers and reduce Public Safety and of
all of the demographics pulled black
Americans fear most for public safety
with 67% acknowledging their concern for
this and this is why President Trump has
taken action calling strong lead for law
and order and peace in our streets and
he's set the tone at the top for mayors
and governors additionally we've had the
hundreds of federal arrests the
executive order that's enhanced our
police departments an operation legend
which I announced yesterday from the
Justice Department and on in honor of
legend Tala Farrow a four year old boy
who was tragically killed in his sleep
in Kansas City and as we head into the
weekend this is our last press briefing
of the week if so I just wanted to make
a plea for peace in our streets because
far too many children have been lost
it's important to know their names it's
important to see their faces and may we
all hold in our prayer and keep close to
our hearts the families of Natalia
Wallace who is seven makai James who is
ten Bernardo Jones Jr who is 14 since
their Gaston who is one Lena Nunez who
is 10 a Maria Maria Jones who is 13
davon McNeil who is 11 and Sakura Turner
down in Atlanta who is eight let's make
sure we have peace in our streets this
weekend and hold these families in our
prayers thank you